check your Six Gang the state trashy
tour is rolling along we're coming to a
city near you little ayg with the crowd
plus a nice stand-up comedy show grab
the squad and come out and see us yeah
next stop is Tampa Florida second show
added low ticket alert there get them
baby then we're going to Dania Beach
Florida Raleigh North Carolina
Louisville Kentucky Cleveland Ohio then
Round And Out Columbus Ohio we're out of
more cities get those Dickies welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit there with your
favorite comedians and we find it at the
group to be classy yeah don't they're
just a big old piece of trash I'm your
host Dave Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're back here in
antodi's in a new addition baby she's
living high on the hog just had a
Jacuzzi put upstairs in the bedroom oh
so it's gonna get a little freaky up
there on a weeknight Steve on don't go
peeking in the room my co-host is coming
at you from right next to me he is the
CEO of Ru garbage he's an international
business man he's my best pal in the
whole wide world and I love them give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan everybody hey
what's up gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate view
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
cooking and then obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage check it
out gang it's a party over there sweet
Lord love that money and how about a
nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good works the ones works the
twos the threes and the fours crosses
the t's and dots the eyes now you can
get a little peek at him ladies but no
touching give it up for T-Bone and
scruffins Toby McMullen everybody there
he is man talk about a guy who laid the
foundation of my like comedy life is
like oh [__] oh man the tits and Super
Troopers changed my life really okay
I'll give you the edited uh
the editing room floor material Kevin's
final count go to Town Gang the long
hair ain't lion man we're ecstatic we
couldn't be more excited to have her
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guests here with us today for the first
time he is a very funny very talented
very successful actor writer producer
comedian director you may have seen him
in but not limited to he got puddle
Cruiser No Looking Back big helium dog
Arrested Development Sky High the lather
effect Curb Your Enthusiasm How I Met
Your Mother strange Wilderness the baby
makers Veep Animal Practice freeloaders
Workaholics Agent Carter uh-oh The
Goldbergs airplane mode scoob The Fairly
OddParents the Dukes of Hazard and of
course he is one of the members of the
legendary Broken Lizard and has starred
in Super Troopers Super Troopers too
Club dread Beer Fest Tacoma FD the
slamming salmon and he has a brand new
movie out right now on Hulu that you
gotta check out called quasi but the big
question is mine today is he garbage
first thing he said when he walked in is
can I use the pisser yeah that's getting
up that's pretty good the legendary
Kevin and everybody thank you
let me get the piss again
shakes my hand I gotta take a dump kid
yeah excuse me uh wow that's a lot of
intro man thank you buddy you're a
worker man I guess it's true it just
means I'm old no I've been around for a
while killing it yeah all right he's
right man I mean you know I want to kiss
your ass I don't want a fan boy out dude
[__] Super Troopers man sure [__]
started it all yeah forget about it many
years ago it was great yeah that was one
of the ones where somebody with their
hands on a DVD and you were like what
the [__] is that I got it for my older
brother yeah that's what nobody like
went and saw in the theater
people like watch it in dorm rooms
man and then DVDs disappeared and then
we were [__] I probably still have the
Super Troopers dvd people come to our
live shows and they'll show up with the
VHS tape you know what I mean like I
said you sign it you're like what the
[__] is that and also like a T-bone said
I don't get too risque but that pulling
over the German couple scene it is
that's why I married a German girl
because because oh my God now things are
getting kinky yes yes wow okay I think
that was the first time we shot nudity
we didn't even know how to [__] do it
I think it did it yeah you guys are all
standing around sunglasses on I know
what not I think it was like the end of
the day like we were totally [__] up
and the sun was going down we had like
20 minutes you know take off your shirt
and then you feel like a porn director
yeah I mean you're over there smoking a
cigar or something not right now take
your shirt off give us the back story on
Kevin Heffernan yeah ma'am we know
you're a Connecticut guy I'm a
Connecticut cool yeah give us the whole
from West Haven Connecticut there you go
which is west of New Haven okay and
um yeah I grew up there
um how was it was it what do you would
you say parents both work what are we
doing yeah well no Mom was uh at least
in my day she was a stay-at-home mom
okay and uh dad was a lawyer all right
and so uh yeah so he worked uh in West
Haven as a lawyer and Mom uh was the mom
what kind of law was he practicing uh he
did a little bit of everything you know
he was kind of like the local town you
know you know my cousin gets in jail he
goes respect that yeah yeah uh so a
little bit of everything Ronnie let my
idiot nephew out of there right now hey
Uncle Mike can you get me out of prison
uh so there was some of that but you
know and uh you know pretty normal
middle class single family home single
family home brothers and sisters uh one
older brother okay uh one uh younger
sister and then another younger brother
nice yeah all right so so three siblings
uh-huh uh not too shabby kind of
standard American upstairs the sister
still lives in the hometown you know
with the parents very nice with her
family and your parents still live in
the same home that you still live in the
same home we're gonna go up there this
weekend nice yeah now one of the things
we like to ask since they still live in
the house we don't want to give away the
street yeah but is it a street an Avenue
away a drawer a lane it's a street
street the street was a dead end Street
like it's a dead end is it like a nice
dead end or a rough day uh it's I think
it's kind of a nice Dead End by the Long
Island Sound
I did yeah I don't know if that's if
you're allowed to I'm not sure yeah
nobody ever gives you a clear answer
whenever we ask they're like we did but
I don't know I grew up swimming there
and I don't have any cancers yeah and it
was right there in the backyard right
there yeah right there outside the house
you guys have a pool at the house no
they do now okay above ground yeah is
that you know that's not great that's
what I'm talking about that is the worst
of the two options okay okay but they
that's what they have now so when I grew
up there was no pool okay I didn't have
anything to do with that that's all
right what they did after I left their
problem however they want to bring the
property value now that's up to them
I'll have to deal with it when they're
dead I lose money on it if you want to
take the joint go ahead oh that's good
what was the grocery store that your mom
would go to growing up uh we had stop
and shops Stop and Shop Stop and Shop
um yeah I think it was Stop and Shop and
then it turned into like an Ames or
something yeah
Stop and Shop Stop and Shop kid and we
were just talking about pizza obviously
New Haven legendary uh well where were
you going on the reg uh on the reg there
were all there were kind of all
offshoots of the same kind of pizza you
know in New Haven it's Sally's and Pepes
and that's the goods that's the the uh
gold standard I guess you'd say
we would go to a place called Tom and
Pat's okay which I think is still there
sounds pretty good you guys that Tom and
Pat I knew them both and uh you know we
played like Youth Sports together and
then they grew up and they started this
or you know their family and then they
that's over and so we would go there a
lot but then there were a lot of other
ones you know on the would you eat there
yeah all right bring it home this is all
this is all important right to this is
granular yeah we're in it right now okay
yeah no we took it home you take it home
and you know he's ordered more than you
needed yeah that's right because then
you have a couple leftovers let me ask
you this will you have a glass of milk
with your pizza no never I never had
milk I don't think let's see soda
okay it's always soda what was the go-to
soda we're talking uh well it's probably
you know like uh you know when we're
kids it's probably an orange soda or a
grape soda okay now you know it's
probably gonna get a little Coke
but no it's never milk any three liters
floating around the house when you were
a kid oh yeah
I'll be the Pepsi right yeah
yeah exactly and the Pepsis would be
that so okay if there was extra pizza
left over at the end of the night how
would you store it would you put the
whole box in the fridge or would you
take it out tin foil or plastic bag what
did you do uh we would do plastic bags
like Ziploc plastic bag and then the zip
lag would be sitting there for however
many days yeah and you'd go in there and
you'd eat for breakfast yeah or whatever
you like a cold pizza I do I like a cold
pizza all right
I'm sorry one sec on the pizza tip what
uh what's the what was the frozen pizza
growing up do you ever do frozen pizza
uh yeah not so much you know we did a
little bit but it was more like you'd
always have the you know in in the
Connecticut area
just right down the street ever step to
the to the to the corporate side do a
little dominoes little Pizza Hut not
until I got to college yeah growing up
never that's classy right yeah is that
is that yeah is that yeah
I mean you're spoiled you got all that
good pizza but then I would make fun of
the kids who ate Domino's
kidding me look at that get out of here
flat little saw Dusty Square Pizza
I do love it though then you try to thin
crust and it was all turned around it's
all right then I tried the thick crust
and then you know you meet a guy from
Chicago
yeah yeah that'll change that changed my
bowels you know I could never handle it
what was the sports growing up you play
any sports uh yeah I played mostly we
were big Sports family so I played oh I
played hockey football baseball and
basketball very nice yeah man that in
the cycle yeah like not like in any you
know
yeah I mean you know as kids we played
all those Sports growing up and uh what
was the what was the high school mascot
uh well I then I I went to a um Catholic
all boys high school okay uh which was
about which was in Fairfield which was
about 20 minutes away five miles away
and uh our mascot was the Jesuits
it's biblical [__] right there like my
hometown was the West Haven Blue Devils
that's a good one and then um yeah
I went to the Jesuits see right I went
to the Jesuits and uh which is not a
very sexy mask nah it's not the coolest
it's not very good mascot playing the
Corinthians today yeah yeah uh
Richard very good grades are good good
you're good good I know you went to law
school right I did I went to yeah I went
to law school I went to Colgate
University and then I went to law school
that's all right uh do you remember what
you got in the SATs
somewhere mid-12s I think that's good
pretty good I mean you know today kids
are like you know I got you know perfect
score yeah right I got an 870 dude you
did yeah
it took it 18 times yeah I've tried my
hardest here
I was swinging for the fences baby well
now we say kids you know maybe have
learning disabilities sure yeah I was
just dumb back now they have unlimited
time if they want yeah really they can
take it two weekends I'm going back baby
I still got two years eligibility that'd
be [__] funny though if you went back
and studied really hard and see how you
did now get a 640. and then you went to
Harvard that'd be pretty good um what
were the family vacations like growing
up uh all car also like I I never set
foot on an airplane until I was a senior
in high school okay so it was like uh
station wagon you drive up to Boston you
drive up to the Salem witch Museum you
know whatever you know yeah yeah uh
you'd go down to DC and look at The
Monuments okay or you'd go down to
Philly sure look at the Bell
you've got a family trip to PC was that
was something that was great or yeah
Philly we did a bunch of times you go to
the Ben Franklin Museum yeah
what was the first job
first job uh I worked uh cutting grass
at a golf course yeah I worked at a golf
course as well private club yeah uh
public golf course public course yeah
and so uh I would uh cut grass and you
know change whatever holes sure break
traps
around in a golf cart uh a little bit
yeah a little bit we we uh one night we
played actually demolition derby and
yeah a couple guys got fired yeah but I
gotta do it I didn't have to at some
point it just boils over you like that
yeah
um but yeah so that was the first uh did
you goth at all or no I did but like not
good I'm not I wasn't good you know my
dad and his brothers and his friends
they were kind of like more the beer
drinking golfers you know uh they were
not good and so every once while you
play with them or whatever but sure I
was not I'm not a good girl you have a
set of clubs now I have a set of clubs
from 1986. really yeah my parents gave
me a a a set of clubs when I was in high
school okay and I have kept those
since I was sitting there and so like I
remember I was cleaning out my garage
like last year and my neighbor looked
and he goes hey you got some clubs I
said yeah he goes you won't play and I
was like the clubs are from 1986. like
the driver is like you know it was the
size of the golf ball you know what I
mean it's just a little piece of wood
like now yeah they're you know you know
they're huge but hey John Peaks man
they're probably sick I guess so I don't
know I don't know every time you move
you take them with you I do it it's done
my wife's like get rid of the [__]
it's like you know I don't sound a
little value yeah they're just weapons
now if somebody comes someone runs it
somebody comes in that's what you grab
and you take them out you get a little
nine iron
um all right who babysat you growing up
uh had some older cousins
that would do that and then um we would
have uh like you know Friends of the
family's older kids would do it okay um
which you know I recently actually
connect like I got a an email uh
randomly because they're a fan of the
shows or whatever from the daughter of
one of the people that really babysit me
and she's like you know the woman's like
in her 60s now you know and so I and
then I was just thinking about she
probably has some very nostalgic stories
but all I can think about is the
Heffernan kids terrorizing the [__] out
of her I remember like there were times
my parents would have to get two
babysitters because it was you watch
that one you watch the other one and
like you know you know we had that
climbing our Windows running away yeah
you know saying wait till my mom comes
home that kind of [__] yeah yeah and
then your mom comes like that is the
daughter of my best friend and you treat
her like [__]
that's what we're looking for that's
always that that's a huge thing who
babysat is a big is it really oh okay I
won't let you know if someone
or like my older brother my older sister
that's a little on the classy side the
Foley's we had this neighborhood lady
um who was a little on the side okay
little on the slower side how many
foleys were there that she was watching
it was me and my brother who's 18 months
older than me and like you was
terrorized we would go to bed and come
down we would wait for like an hour and
a half and come down and she'd be
sitting in a recliner watching TV and
we'd sneak up behind her and we would
just yank back to the chair okay all
right we called it was it an era where
that she could smack you or no yeah she
smacked us a couple of times but she
started to bring in another lady who was
smacking she was the muscle she's a
weightlifter but she was also on the
slower side too so it was chaos okay my
mom would come home freaking out okay
but that's all right okay uh what was
your first your first car
I did not own a car until I was 30 years
old really yeah and um we were never
guys that had my family we didn't have
cars didn't have one at College didn't
have one at College at all no I I you
know relied on other people take the
train yeah you know I had people give me
rides but not until I could get my own
car
and then it was a Honda I think it was a
Honda Civic all right hatchback
uh uh little SUV oh like a CR not a
Civic yeah CRV
your first car was a CRV yeah yeah but
it was like you know the CRVs now are
much nicer than the others it wasn't one
of those High ends 20 years ago man this
is one of the shitties look at what
color are we talking black
or used when you got it I got new I got
it new there you go got a good deal had
a guy yeah he helped me you pegged me as
a good deal guys
yeah I had a guy help me out and you
never you never worked as a lawyer right
uh I never worked officially as a lawyer
like I worked uh I'll do your willing
yeah you know because I like a paralegal
type stuff I was a paralegal for many
years uh here in New York City and then
uh after we started making movies and it
wasn't going well I was a like a temp
lawyer gotcha were you just like read
documents and stuff like that but that
was it that was as far as it all went
for me so you were living in New York I
lived here for 15 years yeah oh [__]
yeah where at yeah uh I lived in every
neighborhood I lived uh in the West
Village then I moved to Chelsea then I
moved to Soho uh then upper east side
and Upper West Side you guys like Zillow
over here I knew it all I knew all the
neighborhoods what was the pet situation
growing up uh had it a dog and a cat
Okay dog was a mutt dog's name Panda
because it was black and white that's
fun cat's name cat's name my sister
butterscotch because it was the color of
butter
have you seen a theme
that's what it looked like I guess yeah
indoor cat outdoor cat uh indoor dogs
stayed inside did you have a dog house
in the back uh dog stayed inside but we
had a you know yard so the dog did spend
a lot of time out who was cutting the
grass over at your house me you did it
riding mower push mower push mower uh
when I first started we had a uh uh you
know one of the manual ones
you know yeah I never understood how
those worked that's when I when I first
started doing it and then I was like you
know hey Dad come on spring [__] up
you're a lawyer yeah that's got to be a
brutal Saturday afternoon dude it's true
and so then we got to the uh uh the
power mower and that's you know that's a
game changer yeah it was a game changer
and also you know I was a professional
grass cutter at the golf course so I
took over sure
let me take care of this I mean look I'm
gonna look nice you could be able to
putt in this backyard I'll give you the
strips what were you what were you
riding around on where they were
tractors at the golf course I assume
they were tractors on the golf course
yeah and all well that and you do push
mowers there oh no yeah yeah okay on the
smaller stuff yeah yeah and that they
had the blades real close you cut the
greens too yeah really yeah you have to
go around you're going to five five a.m
cut the greens before the golf
everything with a golf course was I was
I remember getting up for work I was
like 17 at like 4 30 yeah what the hell
am I doing here because they had to beat
them before they get on First Tee Time
was like 604 or something like that
getting there before the sun came up and
then that first round caddy and your
feet would be soaked because they either
watered or there was Dew all over the
thing yeah you have grass clippings and
all that [__] on your stuff yeah there's
nice boots uh ruin your waterproof boots
butcher box put your box put your box
one more time we got butcher box baby
premium mules don't have to come at a
premium price butcher box lets you stick
to your budget while eating well with
high quality meat and seafood you can
trust feel great about what you're
putting into your body because as you
know it's very important around these
parts butcher box uses only 100
grass-fed B free range organic chicken
pork raise crate free and wild caught
Seafood baby
uh as you know they we've been big fans
for years they've been sending those
truckloads of stuff it's fantastic I'm
on it the wife wanted Hans eats and
everybody loves that butcher box baby
you're ready to cook cuts are delivered
straight to your doorstep with recipes
Inspirations and fun tips and hacks to
make your mirror make your meals the
best ever you'll also receive exclusive
member deals and free shipping every
single gosh darn time to get free
chicken thighs for a year that's right
free chicken thighs for a year and 20
off your first box when you sign up
today that's three pounds of bone-in
chicken thighs free in every box for a
year plus 20 bucks off your first order
when you sign up at butcherbox.com
ayg and use code ayg uh claim this deal
at butcherbox.com
ayg and use code ayg do it rocket money
rocking money rocket money three two one
lift off eighty percent of Americans
have subscriptions they've forgotten
about chances are you're part of that
statistic as well rocket money formerly
known as true built can make sure you
aren't wasting tons of money on on
subscriptions you don't even use uh
rocket money is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscription monitors your spending and
helps your helps you lower your bills
all in one place maybe they got it all
over there to cancel subscription just
press cancel at just press cancel it's
as easy as that they take care of the
rest for you I had I didn't use it until
uh they became a sponsor I signed up
found out I was paying like 22.99 a
month for some stupid service I signed
up for three years ago and then they
canceled it and that's money back in my
pockets baby money I can go to the bar
with most Americans think they spend
about 80 on some subscriptions each
month and most Americans are wrong that
actual number is closer to 200.
rocket money can give you back a huge
chunk of your monthly budget so you have
more wiggle room to spend on things that
matter like booze uh get rid of useless
subscriptions with rocketmoney.com go to
rocketmoney.com garbage seriously it
could save you hundreds of dollars a
year I'm talking bones I'm talking clams
I'm talking C notes that's
rocketmoney.com garbage cancel your
unnecessary subscriptions with
racketmoney.com garbage baby the links
in the show notes do we're not back to
the show what about uh any injuries as a
kid do you ever break anything fall out
of a tree I broke my thumb skiing okay
and um I was I was never a good skier
but you know when you lived in we lived
in the Northeast would your family go or
would you go with your friends uh my
family never went skiing together I
don't think I ever saw my Dad or Mom on
skis uh yeah like we went like I went
with like um you know the high school
trip gotcha or whatever it is sure and
you know and uh I broke my thumb that's
the only break I had did you ever ski in
jeans oh yeah oh definitely that ain't
good definitely I know but it's like
before like I I see now like my kids you
know they'll go skiing and they're not
we live in L.A so they don't go skiing
very much but you know it's all this
kind of state of the art sure of course
you know we would just go with you know
the shitty you know gloves or mittens
and sure well we talked about we've
talked about a lot on the show of like
stuff back then in the 70s 80s and 90s
was so hard to come across and so
expensive yeah now you're like oh I need
to keep pants I'm going tomorrow and
they're at your house like my mom would
put the Wonder Bread bag inside the boot
did you guys ever have that Wonder Bread
back inside the boot and then you put
the boot on we would do a rubber band
around our ankles okay people from
falling down and to cut your circulation
so in case frostbite said it it was easy
that's right you said you said that your
dad
um your dad was more of a have a beer in
golf what kind of beer did you Pop drink
growing up um they were Budweiser guys
um and then
um so my uncles yeah we had all the
hefrans lived in this town so it's like
their five brothers and uh and my uncle
always had beer in his um garage so it
was like you know like well Connecticut
is weird because like you know they
don't sell on Sundays and they stop at
eight Pennsylvania is the same yeah
eight o'clock blue laws whatever you're
done and so it'd always be like go over
Uncle Bill's house get a couple cases
out of his garage
would have Miller Lite there you go you
go over to get Miller Light from him so
then you bring it back over did you guys
have a second refrigerator in your
garage
garage freezer we had you had a freezer
yeah like one of those uh you know sure
open up yeah
meat meat yeah yeah you put some meat in
there any hunters in the family no no no
okay so no venison or anything no
venison just you know Hamburger cool a
lot of burgers like they're Birds
there's a lot of hamburger you know so
we can make goulash were you allowed to
eat in your room as a kid yeah you are
yeah what do you guys would have dinner
you sit down at the table or you guys
sit down in front of the TV table nice
to the table here respectable yeah no TV
how many times was their family dinner a
week was it once a week or were you guys
everything pretty much every every night
pretty much every night and what's your
folks nationality uh Irish Irish yeah
we're like you know 75 Irish what would
your mom uh what would your mom cook
what was her best dishes
um
tuna in a in a hot dog roll
like a Hot Tuna in a in a in a hot dog
roll
uh that was one of the Irish aren't good
Cooks my family as well my mom good my
mom doesn't even try she goes I'm not a
good cook ladies and gentlemen the
podcast took what we call a left turn
around right around here I bet it was
good tuna though it was good it was good
um but that's kind of stuff like goulash
you know she'd make like you know
something yeah you know a lot of eggs
noodles growing up you have egg noodle
yeah you get like the the beef uh or a
tuna casserole okay kind of casserole is
another thing
pasta mushroom soup and tuna which I've
tried to make for my kids and they can't
[__] believe that I ate that when I
was a kid my mom does it with chicken
she calls it chicken all the crumb yeah
okay we had that kind of stuff and cream
bread crumbs on top yeah yeah we had
that too what was the uh the snack
situation no vegetables just so you know
no regular no vegetables I don't have
broccoli till I was 18. yeah that I'm
serious yeah yeah like now I like you
know I forced my parents to buy
vegetables because I feel like you know
maybe a potato was like the most the
biggest vegetable potatoes yeah pasta
meat potatoes do them in the oven
wrapped in tin foil yeah all right I
like it what's this what was the snack
situation
snack situation they have sweets in the
house no we were not a sweet family
we're not a sweet family probably have
like a potato chip was probably the big
thing okay like probably potato chips
okay yeah okay we were not a sweet spot
we didn't have desserts
you know like I when I got married my
wife's family is a big dessert family
and they couldn't even understand how we
couldn't be a dessert fan yeah and so
you know I don't respected what was uh
what were the how what was Christmas
like you do a real tree fake tree always
real tree real tree always real tree
colored lights white lights uh colored
lights okay colored lights White's a
little class here right white class here
how about I do that now there you go
it's your new money that's right that's
right because that's super true because
I've grown up a little bit yeah I've
grown up a little bit
but no we did the you know we had the
colored lights and any tinsel on the
tree cut lots of tinsel on the tree the
dogs eating it and [__] yeah that's bad
yeah and then uh but it was you know
sloppy tinsel on the tree outside of the
house colored lights as well yes color
lights as well okay yeah all right not
icicle lights like those you know big no
no sure okay old school baby not bad you
have carpet in the bathroom growing up
no no tile you ever have the uh tile
family the carpeted toilet seat you know
the the cover the cover on the seat or
right around yeah like in the softer you
know the softer thing we um uh we did at
one point end up having carpet in the
kitchen
whoa which is [__] crazy and stupid
dude that's a first stupid this is
episode like 288 and then like I think
just last weekend my brother was up
there and he ripped the carpet out of
the kitchen Jesus what kind of carpet we
talking like you know like you know this
space shag you know but it was like
but yeah I mean the amount of [__] you
spill in the kitchen I mean like
somebody would say like an office like
thinner yes yes with 30 years of bacon
grease yeah exactly yeah commercial
carpet in the kitchen yeah that's enough
we got a company coming over vacuum the
kitchen yeah shout out to Mr and Mrs
Hefner that's crazy whoa did you collect
anything growing up
um
I did baseball cards cool football cards
cool comic books I did cool
um any Chinese stars or nunchucks no my
brother was that guy my brother he was
the uh he was the Asian influence guy
okay so he did uh yeah nunchucks he did
Stars he did you know all kind of you
know he took uh Judo lessons karate
lessons and that kind of stuff so he was
that guy very nice and I was a little
bit more Sporto okay you know the sports
cards and the uh comic books any uh any
musical instruments in the family
anybody play the piano the guitar not
until we had to like that well that was
like school right yeah you take band or
whatever and so I played the saxophone
uh for a few years Alto there you go
yeah there you go I was not I was not
good okay uh but you could hold your own
I assume that I guess I was okay I mean
I was still I used to hold the note I
still like to say I played the saxophone
there you go really yeah I was never
gonna hold the note but you know you own
assassin phone
I don't I don't
um I should though right I mean if
you're going around saying you play the
saxophone
like I spent several years playing the
saxophone okay it's kind of a big guy uh
instrument sure sure uh you know it's
not like I played the clarinet just you
know very soon
but that was I was that guy and then my
sister I think played the flute there
you go and uh other than that no my
parents were not you know musical people
at all okay at all okay were you a chess
family no nobody plays chess uh you know
there might have been a span where one
of my brother brothers was into it but
no we were not we were more Checkers
than chess I like it were you more of uh
were you more Jeopardy definitely
Fortune most Checker families are Wheel
of Fortune I feel like as time went on
maybe it was there was a Jeopardy in
there okay a little bit more of a
Jeopardy in there but you guys watch any
shows together as a family uh
not like I would watch shows with my dad
I don't know if we ever I mean as the
kids we'd come together and watch you
know whatever sure The Cosby Show or
whatever you know that show was
um with my parents I definitely would
watch like mash sure my dad watched and
I watch shows together sure like do you
guys know the white shadow of course do
you know that show yeah one of my
all-time favorite shows like my dad and
I watched that together high school
basketball it's a great show and so you
know we would watch that stuff together
but I don't I can't think of us sitting
down as a family guy and watching it
together any other shows you and your
pop would watch would you would watch
the Hill Street Blues there you go sane
elsewhere there you go uh yeah the white
shadow and then we watch Yankee games
together that's awesome man and Giants
games together that's awesome so so
that's the way you leaned even in
Connecticut you were Yankees yeah well I
think the Mason-Dixon line is New Haven
okay and so people on the other side
were the Boston New England right and
then and then and the towards you know
you go towards Fairfield or whatever
that that was more Yankees New York New
York baseball Boston yes I respect it
yeah were you a Mayo family growing up
was there Mayo in the house yes very
much so and still was there helmet was
it Hellman's or Miracle Whip Hellman's
excellent but you know what they don't
have that in the west coast it says it's
a totally different America's best I
can't remember it's a different brand
like you get out there like what the
[__] it's the same exact product labels
and whatever but it doesn't say yeah
yeah uh isn't that crazy you guys were
you guys I smell a stand-up bit all
right guys work on it well I have
something for me about tomorrow yeah
give me give me five minutes on helmets
guys what's the deal um uh where was the
butter kept growing up in the fridge or
on the counter
um
this is a bone of contention now I keep
it on the counter General because I
think that's where it should be of
course uh I think growing up it was in
the fridge I'm surprised I am too but
just because Irish mom old school carpet
in the kitchen yeah I would think that
the butter would be on like me too and
that's why I that's the fight we have
now it's like how why when we were
growing up why don't you put the butter
on the counter yeah Mom what's hard
butter on their toast yeah I never never
processed them until we got older and I
realized that it's got to be spreadable
baby yeah but it was never we had the
hard bar it's not like we had tubs you
have tubs I grew up we grew up a
margarine family I guess
when I was a little older for a minute
my mom got into the whipped butter okay
correct Stones yeah yeah that's all
right that was a little better yeah
classy fancy yeah at times when times
are going we're good over there things
were good for a couple years in the 90s
what was your first concert uh Jay geils
Band what do you guys think about that
blood runs cold uh
it was a New Haven Coliseum okay and uh
we got tickets to J geils and I went
with my buddy from high school and
um I don't know it's probably like 15
maybe I would imagine it's a good time
and uh um the opening band was a guy who
I'd never heard of and never heard of
since uh he was like a Jimi Hendrix his
name was John Butcher axis you ever
heard him you ever heard him I love him
tickets next week yeah he's coming in
later today no don't know what happened
to him he he opened up uh for them and
uh it was the first time I saw someone
smoking weed too okay because I was like
you know there are people all around me
they're smoking weed and me and my high
school buddy you're like what's going on
man and um and I had nightmares that
night and my mom attributed to the weed
smoke it's just that smoke honey wait
you went home and told her guys we're
smoking weed yeah yeah yeah I was you
know open about it you know but the
funny thing is now is my son who's that
age now
um for you know whatever we have our
first concert that we said it's this
what's your first concert right and
everyone has them sure what are you guys
I'm sure you've talked about it Steve
Miller Band okay I went with my mom I
was probably eight it was Meatloaf Bat
Out of Hell but still that's great that
was a good time so my son went to his
first concert with my my daughters and
Mom and it's Katy Perry and forever for
his life that's tough someone will ask
him what your first concert is and it'll
be Katy Perry yeah and that's his
[__] curse
being fair being fair he's got some hot
tracks the actual first concert I went
to I went with my mom and my two cousins
that are a little bit older than me it
was Jack Wagner okay from the General
Hospital
[Laughter]
he had one big hit uh too young nope no
that's that's of the time when you when
you search for Jack Wagner's biggest hit
a shocking number of song comes so this
guy's got quite a cattle well he was
multi-talented he's a hyphenated person
lady of my heart nope that's not it
going back again no stay where you are
nope all I need that's it all I need is
just a little more time
so you can just forget the forget the
Katy Perry who was your mom's favorite
singer who did they lose your mom and
dad listen to Peter Paul and Mary okay
responsible my dad had the um
my dad my dad listened to the Kingston
Trio uh you guys don't even know what
they are all right folk guys right so
then and my dad also he had yeah
he's all right
um uh uh we went to Cole my dad went to
Cole University also and so there's a
men's singing group okay called the
Colgate 13. that's old and my dad had
some buddies that were on it when he was
there and he had their album so he for
to this day you know 40 years he that's
what he listened the Colgate 13.
so yeah so he's not he doesn't like any
rock and roll than like anything like
that you put it on it could be the
stones or Katy Perry and he's like what
the [__]
he wants the Kings and Trio
Britannica
um we didn't have Britannica but it was
a different it was the cheaper knockoff
version okay but yeah you get them and
and that's how you'd write your uh
reports from school hey get the the um
any any other series of magazines were
any other uh or any of the letters
missing in your no completely we were
pretty good we were pretty good about
that that's awesome that and The Hardy
Boys books we had all the set he had The
Hardy Boys he had a complete set
priorities so National Geographic any
other set series my brother had National
Geographic which you know had the the
breasts yeah um you know from whatever
third world country breasts yeah and um
shout out to them
yes it was the Columbia encyclopedias
yes sir good job yeah good I like it
good how do you get your steak cooked
like like now or what then now uh I go
like medium rare gentlemen the ball my
kids go um my kids go you know well done
and I I correct them in the restaurant
really you don't want them you don't
want that well done don't grow out
waiter don't listen to them
I'm paying a bill all right they don't
want that get the medium plus uh a
medium plus a medium plus uh how many
suits do you own and do you know how to
tie a tie uh I do I definitely know how
to tie a tie I'm not good at I mean like
I don't know how to tie a fancy tie like
when I worked in town here
um and I was a paralegal you'd have to
wear tires entire every day and so I
knew the fast way to tie a tie like I
don't know how to do like a wins or
double windsor yeah I don't know I only
know one quick one yeah I know quick one
and I still use to this day and people
make fun of me but you know and I've had
people be like no no come on and then
they re-tie you or whatever but and
Suits I had
like some shitty suits for a long time
that I wore when I was a paralegal and
then I started wearing them when we
would do promotional stuff and then
people get mad at me like you can't wear
the [__] suit apparently idiot yeah
like a [__] idiot and um so then uh
my sister-in-law who is our wardrobe
designer on our movies and our TV shows
she's I'm gonna take you shopping that's
awesome I'm gonna take you shopping so
we went shopping and I got a I got I got
one nice suit and so that's it what's
her name
you know I wouldn't know if he told me I
would I would know it something
something like a designer suit yeah yeah
it's something yeah
it's like two grand maybe all right
that's the suit that's the but that's
you'll be buried in that God that's
right and then like when I and I when I
fluctuate in weight which happens you
know you try to go up you go down you
gotta take it in you gotta take it out
all right I respect that man I love it
hickey uh uh hickey do you guys know
suits no no I don't know suits I don't
like Hugo Boss and stuff yeah no no it's
something I don't know okay
um who's cutting the hair now who cuts
the hair
um Sports Clips I go to Jesus
is there sports clips out here you're a
goddamn movie
got him out of here well I've always
been that guy like like uh Sports Clips
whenever at least a haircut well they
get mad at me right I I um when I lived
here I would always find like the barber
you know whatever the like the local
Barbers yeah like out here like out
there it's a Mexican barber shop now
here it's like the Puerto Rican guy a
lot of Eastern Europeans that's right so
that I would always find that Barbershop
for five bucks here whatever it would be
and and I would go to that and then um
when you're doing the movie or the TV
show you have the person you know do
your hair so you know for the last three
or four seasons we've done our show I'll
get my hair cut by that woman you know
in the trailer every week every week and
they were going for like three months
and then as soon as it was done I would
go back to Sports Clips and she'd get
[__] furious at me right so we just
come to my I was like yeah Sports Clips
is right by my house and it's just you
know I mean I just get a you know the
little cut you know a little [__] cut
David Sports Clips at La they have a lot
of them
regular
I'm a regular I I do have a Punch Cards
I don't use it I use it for my son
because he's like he thinks it's funny
to use that he thinks it's fun to use a
punch okay I'll give you that but I do
know what's up what's up two weeks ago
you got a TV show with a brand new movie
what what's it what's it cost what's it
what's it cuts at your back over there
it's gone up since the pandemic
inflation
no I think it's like 20 now I think it's
20. and what do you tip if you don't
mind us ask um I tip well yeah I tip
well okay I'll give uh like if I do like
a 20 bucker I'll give like a 15 Buck tip
or a 10 bucks respectable yeah
all right man thank you so much fancy
it's classy ah if you're staying in a
hotel what do you tip uh what do you
leave for the uh the chamber made uh it
depends how many days but um you know if
I'm there like for a weekend I'll throw
like a 20 down if I'm there for more
then we got to throw 40 down okay guys I
just thrown around I threw a 40 down for
this I was here for like four days I
threw a 40 time
but that's
not you don't throw anything down
in my lean years yeah all right but
let's say you go do the Jacksonville
whatever yeah whatever it is no we're
tipping now you're tipping you're
throwing it in there we were jammed up
for a long time yeah we were I stiffed
enough that I
but I feel like I need to pay it back
the generations now me too that's
exactly right also we sell merch I'll
usually have a lot of cash of like you
know so I'll leave yeah probably at
night I try to go 10 bucks a night okay
because I try to do that okay all right
that's nice yeah do you guys share a
room on the road no we're too old if we
would have hit if we would have got
successful when we were like 22-23 for
sure but it's like he's 47 and I'm 36
sure we're like but that's the agreed
but we do Five Guys to a room we used to
do five guys to a room and then you're
like oh [__] what are you kidding me the
whole Squad would be in there and then
you'd get like a little split up you
know two and three or whatever and now
it's like [__] it sure we can't I can't
do it where'd you stay when you were
here can I ask you that here yeah uh I
stayed at a place because I had my
family so we sit in a place where you
got uh they were kind of short-term
apartment oh nice should I say the name
of it or no that's up to you it was a
place called The Phillips Club very nice
it sounds nice it sounds crazy it's not
it's not look you know super looking it
was good because like a kitchen yeah
it's great yeah the whole team you know
so it was pretty nice did a good job it
wasn't it wasn't the Four Seasons or
whatever the Ritz
okay I got an apartment do you know how
to use chopsticks
uh I I do it's well I laugh because it
just happened there tonight like I I
don't not great you can get I can use
them if I have to sure but I am the guy
who asked for a fork so we went to a
Japanese restaurant they're not my
family my kids were teenagers
embarrassed the [__] I'm I was like you
know the guy brings the food there good
with it their mom's good with it
and the guy comes to the fork and you
know he probably had in his [__]
here's the [__] Fork here you go and
then I ate my whatever with a fork that
idiot table four what's a four yeah
everyone looks at you yeah everyone
looks at you I struggle through it so
I'm not great with them at all and do
you get a fork if other people I won't
be the first guy to get a fork just out
of Pride okay I'll struggle through it
okay yeah and also I go pride in it or
Direction I'm like yeah give me a
[__] give me a [__] yeah stop doing
the pledge of allegiance yeah yeah
I want a fork okay I'll see my writer
anybody speak uh another language in my
family yeah no no no no no no no no
other languages all right no I wish yeah
now my kids you know they take you know
Spanish do you own any turquoise jewelry
uh no me personally no yeah I do not and
I don't think I ever have not a jewelry
guy never happens no change just the
wedding no change just the wedding ring
watch nice that's it no jewelry no
tattoos cologne no cologne no cologne uh
but you know
I joke about it because my buddy Steve
Lemmy you know he he's a Cologne guy but
he's not what he says he's a body spray
guy and that there's a difference that
body spray is a thing and cologne is
like from Cologne Germany or whatever
like that has to be sure okay and so uh
he wears cologne and uh or he wears body
spray and then we get into arguments
about it but I don't I'm not a cologne I
never have been I feel like I should
maybe I should be yeah I'm not either
but then you got to pick Ascent you got
to figure out what your thing is I do a
little Spritz or something I keep her I
keep her rolling okay can you say what
it is Pam
it's the whip butter we talked about
before
mine's from a town called balloon is it
body spray or is it cool it's cologne I
don't know what it is uh it couldn't lie
to me you buy it in the [__] bulk
yeah tell me what it is
I go through different ones you know
whatever is that like whatever you
whatever the season is yeah whatever the
season you have your winter sandal you
don't want to go too heavy in the summer
sure I hear you okay but yeah in the
last 365 days have you taken a shower
gotten out and put on the same pair
underwear you had before yes
well I feel like when you're on the road
you're running low you know what I mean
you got to throw something back on again
I did that recently it's like you feel
good until you get out here it just
doesn't feel right it's like getting in
bed with someone else but it sometimes
it has to happen socks too socks I've
done that too you know socks are the
same size you currently have matching
socks on right now I do I do I do that's
a thing have you ever traveled somewhere
with dirty clothes in your suitcase yes
definitely for sure but only a place
where I know that I like have access to
laundry you know I mean like if I travel
to my parents or I go to a like a VRBO
that has a you know what's the last time
you did laundry at your parents I'm
gonna do it tonight
mom come in with a full bag of [__]
so tonight I'm tonight I'm gonna let's
stay in the shower for a second okay
move over buddy
are you would you ever brush your teeth
in the shower yes pee in the shower yes
definitely oh man this guy's all right
definitely real straight shooter here
what are you uh what are you using at
the house your house now yeah what's in
the shower I am not uh I I don't have a
lot of yeah I don't I use a soap
straight up soap like a like a Yar bar
yeah you know I'll go we were an Irish
Spring family yeah sure for many years
now I think it's lever or lever lever
lever I think yeah is it okay now we're
that and then um I don't do a hair
product really so
um I just recently started using
conditioner uh which is a new thing
how often
rolling in
yeah
but that being said my wife you know she
has a lot of you know sure stuff in
there and you walk in there and
sometimes you'll use what's in there
okay but I use whatever's in the shower
okay okay now do you use a washcloth no
I used to you just go bar to skin yeah
barter skin I used to do washcloth for a
long time for many many years do you do
the legs too or do you just like gravity
not anymore
I also the thing is and and everyone
makes fun of me we did an episode about
on my shows I don't I hate moisturizer I
don't use it I don't like it I hate it
and so I'm always Ash and you know they
see what the dry skin yeah elephant
elbows they call me you know what I mean
and I'm like that also my wife is a
moisturizer and I'm just always [__]
dry yeah it's gross you floss it every
day
no I'm like I'm like uh pick one of
those picks you know I'll use that okay
just but like it's it's more of an
absent mind and like when I'm sitting on
my desk kind of thing it's not like a
it's not like a noble yeah correct but
it's the same thing right I mean as long
as you do it doesn't matter the intent
you're getting [__] what's the
toothpaste at the house Colgate you're
using Colgate yeah when I went to school
there so gotta support the team we've
always been a couple
and it's this that's the shaving cream
too it's Colgate product okay yeah shave
every day
ah pretty much I don't need to okay it
might be just habit do you use
disposable razors or do you have like uh
I have I have a Gillette but I have like
um I I don't go through I like to use
the same razor for like five months like
you know like uh you guys probably had
that right when we hit the podcast and
it was Harry's was the shower
and so they give you the um it's a big
like they give you the razor and the
thing and then and my buddy Steve Lammy
who's Latin and much more you know hairy
than I am and he was very excited and I
was like ah I don't care I mean I only
go through one they just gave you a
lifetime supplier I have one blade so
it's not really like I would need
Harry's where I need all these blades
available yeah sure
except when you're doing that read yeah
that's true that's true that's true then
you love them you love the sheets and
the things and all the sections first
one every day yeah he was a sex toy
every day
I got a butt plug-in right now yeah and
I love it shout out though okay uh have
you ever won your high school class ring
uh I wore I got one okay I wore it maybe
for a week and then I had a girlfriend
uh and she took it and she wore it like
they put like a ribbon about it so it
fits her finger okay and she wore it I
think she'd lost it she wore it for like
a year or two okay and then okay that's
very you know movie style I like that
well actually there's a class ring yeah
she wore she wore my ring for a while
yeah what's the uh what's your sleeping
situation king size bed yes king size
how many pillows are you using uh I am a
two pillow guy behind your head uh one
behind the head one like under the arm
Choice yeah because my wife doesn't like
she doesn't want me to touch her
honestly I got the same time my wife was
like you know I got hot flashes or
whatever it is I don't want you to touch
me sure I said come on honey no don't
touch me and so I have to have I have to
have something to put my arm away you
have a fan on when you guys go to sleep
no I hate fan okay I hate I don't I
think I I feel like you wake up and
there's like a film on you when there's
a fan I didn't know what you're talking
I'm saying like it feels like
something's been blowing on you no I
kind of get like it yeah will you sleep
with the TV on fall asleep with the TV
no uh it depends if I'm drunk if I'm in
a hotel room yes
the only problem with the hotel room
it's so bright it lights up the whole
room yeah I gotta have it for scary
purposes yeah oh really yeah I wanted to
know somebody's in here I don't want the
maid I stiff three years ago to come
back again
uh yeah I guess hotel room or like if my
wife is like you know working overnight
or something like that I'll I'll
sometimes fall asleep with the TV on all
right all right and the last 365 days
have you slept in jeans no I don't wear
jeans much anymore I mean I wear like uh
khakis khaki jeans I don't wear uh
dungarees
dungarees that's what my dad still calls
them hey get your dungarees and get some
dry cleaned and pressed with a crease he
does real old school his dungarees he
thinks they're his thing and everybody
that's classy when you're getting
dressed in the morning what goes on
first
uh
pants or socks socks always before pants
good man oh well because the guy like me
I have a little you know and you sit
down you don't have your pants on when
you're putting your socks on yeah yeah
it's a restriction you know it's a
restricting issue I'm with you I like it
yeah anyone in your family pronounce
refrigerator as refrigerator
no fridge no that's no that's fine
that's the abbreviation no no no nobody
says refrigerator anyone in your family
ever been on the local news
in a bad way or a good way you tell me
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah well I have
I have like family guys who are
firefighters
that's great they are on for that kind
of thing like and they always send me
the clip you know that's why they're on
I was on the TIC in Connecticut that's
fine if it was a guy who had seen the
fire yeah
and like his hair's all blown away
that's a bad guy yeah yeah we don't we
don't have that yeah you don't want to
be the passerby yeah have you or any
member of your family ever claimed to
have seen a UFO uh I'm sure they have I
don't believe in them okay so I don't uh
I've never claimed that okay uh but I'm
sure by family members who have yeah
like my brothers or my sisters okay
definitely but I'm not a I'm not a ghost
guy or a UFO guy I don't believe in
ghosts I don't believe in you the same
way I don't believe it ghost unless I'm
by myself and it's dark out but right
now I don't believe in ghosts you guys I
believe in serial killers yes and and
murderers ghosts I don't believe it yeah
I also believe in those as well muggers
believe in muggers uh have you ever
microwaved bacon oh yeah hell yeah to
this day yeah turkey bacon now shout out
to it watching the figure I respect it
not bad what's a uh what's a Heffernan
family vacation like now now it's it's a
little bit it's a little more yeah not
not I don't think you know it's not
super luxury but like you know like I
said when we went we didn't you know we
got in the car and drove on drugs but
now you know for example well this was a
family vacation okay I came here you've
been working all week but they come they
come for the fun things and so uh I
brought them with me on this and that's
their vacation nice take them to Disney
World make the production company pay
for it yep Disney World we've done yep
have they been uh have you had the kids
overseas
uh or anywhere do they have their
passports yeah
it's not a great story but yeah but yes
um I have not taken my wife I don't love
traveling overseas okay my wife does and
so she planned this huge trip with and
she was taking the kids to France while
I was shooting my TV show and um this
summer and it was they're so excited and
then it got about a week out and you she
found out that your passport has to be
um uh six months six months yeah and it
was four it won't let you leave yeah
yeah and so the night before the trip
she found that out and so their whole
[__] got tripped that [__] up but I
didn't realize that because I don't go
there yeah so no so I I think the most
uh taking them to Canada that's the best
I've done I in Hawaii does that count
yeah that's still America yeah yeah it's
still America but you know but otherwise
no I took him to the Toledo one day we
went to England went to London there you
go uh that's a good a couple years ago
okay there you go all right well
traveled why don't you like leaving the
country
uh I think the rest of the world isn't
isn't uh there there's chairs and
they're okay Vehicles aren't big enough
okay you know like if you get on a bus
if you get a bus somewhere big enough I
thought it was gonna be political or
something at all it's that uh it's these
goddamn European chair maker but every
time I go somewhere yeah you can't sit
in something or whatever and I feel like
the [__] like the beds and the whatever
they're just not big enough everything
is my uh yeah my wife is is from Europe
every time you go the beds are small
everything's a smaller low profile it's
just not as comfortable and luxurious as
America and then I'm like I I love the
food I don't have a political problem
with it whatever it is I just I feel
like shit's not big enough that's
[__] awesome I don't disagree I think
that's the truth
I might be the best dancer I've ever
heard
[Laughter]
I know you said uh you were a big Tipper
if you're going to a wedding you know uh
maybe like uh you know like uh a family
like a younger family member or like a
close friend's kids now what do you what
do you what are you dropping there uh it
depends that's rough because I don't
know um I'm trying to think
yeah well we're too low uh We've ran the
game we've had crazy high and crazy lows
so you'll fall in the middle I would say
you know before I was you know I would
say
in the last five years I've kind of
settled around like 750.
Trump what in the envelope yeah that's
great holy [__] that's great but what is
that Eliza too much no that's [__]
awesome what do you mean I would say
like that's the last time and before
that it was probably five you know 500
750. that's where I am great you're
doing hundreds
checks oh I think checks that's fine
check it already yeah checking a wedding
it's 750 like you know that's hot dude
but like are you and your wife and
that's yeah that's good that's very good
okay that's awesome very good yeah
they're like the minimum would be like a
hundred a person
that's trash I feel like I used to do
250 like my wife and I was getting 500
but now we've graduated that's great
also because there's a lot of
expectations that's what I'm saying I'm
in the entertainment industry sure they
open it up
but it's the same thing with tipping you
know like you go somewhere they know who
you are yeah the [__] [__] gave us
you know whatever so you always got it
you're laying heavy I tell you we were
uh we were with we made a movie with
Bill Paxton
and he uh he used to walk around
airports with a with a a roll of 20s in
his pocket and if someone came up and
asked him for an autograph or say like I
heard about 20 give him a 20 and we're
like what the [__] are you doing hey man
you got to keep the fans happy yeah and
I was like wow can you think about that
no me too I'm like [__] that what are
you [__] kidding me 20 bucks to
everybody who says Heidi I was sad when
he died that makes me even sad yeah he
was [__] awesome he was one of the
greatest guys I've ever met no question
about chat from Weird Science oh yeah
[__] legendary he didn't like that he
didn't like you to bring that up though
really yeah he probably had such a he'd
want to be focused yeah it was the
letters later stuff so he was like Hey
man come on I did a lot of [__] since
chat man of course but he was [__]
man he was brilliant right he's uh great
that's my childhood memory yeah so yeah
you had to be cool about it oh [__] uh
do you open your eyes underwater in the
pool yes I do I do uh but like you know
I'd say in the last this is the pandemic
I have a pool in my house right so uh
I've been goggle yeah yeah okay I've
been going goggle hot tub
yeah but it doesn't work
there's always a caveat with this why
not it worked like I worked for a week
like the blower broke and I never got it
fixed again is it connected to the pool
it's connected to the pool and it gets
hot but it doesn't do bubbles
like I can get it up water yeah but I
can't make it bubble all right I gotta
fix once and then broke again I was like
[__] it I don't give a shot I'll give
you that that's fine are you grilling
out there you got a grill yeah non-stop
I'm a griller who's cutting the grass
uh Gardner well yeah guy nice in L.A you
pay like 20 bucks yeah he'll come cut I
respect whatever what kind of Grill what
kind of Hardware are you working with
this
um I have a um I'm trying to think the
brand it's a built-in no you had Weber
and it's like Blaze or something like
that no it's building it's got the stone
yeah it's built-in uh my brother and I
did it we put it in and uh and so then
hooked it up to the gas from the house
so you don't have to light anything you
know tanks or anything like that do you
have a fridge in the garage now yes you
do what's in there
um beer meat
[Music]
um and then like leftover like whatever
milk or whatever [__] you need in there
what kind of Brews does Kevin Heffernan
like to pop back um I have oh uh a lot I
get like beers as gifts a lot sure you
know like people like what do you want
to give them I want to give you a beer
and so like they'll give me you know
whatever the Exotic craft sure shitload
of that IPA man I love IPA the more
bitter the better I say uh but I also
have you know I bud and Bud Light and
then like I'll have like
you know like the transpo guy on our
thing will give me a case hey you like
this check beer it's from Checkers don't
give me like a case of that and whatever
[__] yeah yeah sounds awesome pretty
good and what are you whipping around
town what kind of car are you driving
now Chevy
Chevy Traverse it's an American boy
right here those seats are big in that
Chevy baby well it's like a you know I
it's the Manny van I call it the Manny
van yeah so it's like you know it's it's
kind of like a minivan on the inside but
man on the outside family man yeah like
I my my wife went out of there all
electric now but I I've just kept my
Chevy so okay what's the life weapon
around then uh she was Tesla for a while
and then we dumped it okay and um now
she's in a like whatever Volvo makes
it's called pole star it's an electric
vehicle
in a while real quick Volvo back in the
80s and 90s they were they were and safe
you guys yeah it's very uh it's like the
Smart Choice yeah driving the kids
around guys I think I only have one or
two more I'm
uh have you already found member Warner
costume or painted your face to go to a
sporting event as an adult
yes uh I'm trying to think the last time
I did it the last time you did it well I
mean like we did it when we were kids so
I had um growing up we had season
tickets the Giants right so the medals
we would go to the Meadowlands all the
time and um you know deathly warped
shirts and jerseys and stuff yeah yeah
um paint my face probably was more in a
high school day
uh I think I wore a referee outfit one
time oh good game boys like I had a
referee shirt whatever like whatever we
did like a sketch or something I was
reference I'm one of the [__] referee
yeah that's fun that's a bit that's fun
that that was pretty good yeah okay but
I also auditioned one time for a referee
uh position I can't remember what movie
it was oh Semi-Pro was the Will Ferrell
basketball movie yeah and I went and
auditioned and I wore the um the ref
shirt you got to the audition you got it
but I didn't get it you got to man you
would have been great didn't get it yeah
thanks um I just got two more one do you
take leftovers from a restaurant yes
okay absolutely and I eat them some
people take them they don't eat them
sure I take them out yeah when you go
make a purchase at like a CVS or
something like that 7-Eleven will you
ever get cash back after register no I
think well I think it's you know it's a
different world nobody uses cash anymore
oh sure like I have some cash in my
wallet but you know nobody ever uses
cash I think the final thing would you
own a pizza cutter do you have a pizza
cutter at the house several excellent
several and like you know we have
novelty ones like you know like there's
like a bicycle one oh that's fine it's
like a you know classy thanks man you
ever make homemade pizzas at the house
yes yeah that was a big pandemic thing
that's pretty cool you make the pizza
with the dough go-to fast food it can't
be in and out okay and it can't be Shake
Shack
talking one of the classics it has to be
Jack in the boxer Taco Bell
Taco Bell this guy's trash is that
not you don't think Panera Bread
Taco Bell I think Taco Bell like my kids
now my son's now into Taco Bell I can
you know he's one of those guys like
he's 15 years old he'll go through the
thing he's like give me five tacos yeah
like oh Jesus okay one final question
been been a hot button issue here on the
podcast for uh a few a few weeks here
yeah
um when you're flying
when you put the seat back oh yeah
I I I believe that's my real estate
that's my I believe it and I and I say
the person in front of me that's his
real estate right but it's my real
estate and because whatever I'm a big
guy a big gut I I need a little are you
okay when the guy in the front of you
drops it down yeah because then you're
going because I believe that I'm
entitled that he's entitled I've never
thought of that that's his space
yeah it's like a family of lawyers yeah
well it's like somebody put your
somebody puts their [__] underneath
their seat where your feet go and it's
like hey buddy move your [__] out of
there yeah that's where my feet go
that's my space and will you say
something yes you will huh yeah and and
uh you like say something like okay yeah
I've done that before and guys like like
what put it in the seat in front of you
yeah
I like it yeah
you guys not are you not recline I'll
recline if the guy in front of me
reclines but I won't start the reclining
I'm the guy who as soon as like we get
the wheels off the ground I'm back
really
I don't I don't recline obviously I'm
I'm a big guy so when somebody does it
in front of me I it depends but you
don't recline out of principle not yet
not really if I do I kind of look back
and make sure that like the tray is not
out and I'll put it back a little bit
okay but what if there's no one behind
you oh yeah what if there's a little kid
behind you yes yes but I'll I'll this
just happened I'll I'll look back and if
he's with his parent I'll say you guys
mind if I if I come back a little bit
just give him a heads up that's a
dangerous thing I had an issue I had an
issue with an old giving them the power
man oh I got mad at you no I kind of did
he like just slammed it down you can't
slam it back that's not cool okay all
right you're just not ease it back
gentlemen okay raise it back but all
right that's my real estate I understand
there wouldn't be a recline button on
that chair if it wasn't or no of course
of course your honor you make a lot of
sense Kevin thank you thank you ladies
and gentlemen Mr Kevin Heffernan I mean
there's a lot going on here
thank you educated
classy family you know
carpet in the kitchen is tough I forgot
about that there's no bouncing back from
that and you've made it it's an ayg
first you've made a couple of move the
hot tub doesn't help you too much yeah
yeah uh yeah 100 trash okay yeah okay
but [__] it awesome man is that a good
thing yeah
okay
oh he's a garbage okay
it's true the garbage the carpet in the
bathroom question came from my house
oh yeah it smells like people he looks
like he keeps it trimmed to beard though
you guys you know that's new he's
typically relatively scratched he's got
Wallace whiskers coming down all right
let's keep it tight gang Mr Kevin
Hartford in the brand new movie out on
Hulu right now Broken Lizard quasi you
have to check it out it's absolutely
fantastic brother we can't thank you
enough thank you guys this is a lot of
fun anything you want the folks out
there to know you can hit him with uh
yeah well uh Tacoma FD we got our shoes
FD the fourth season is done and edited
and it's sitting there and we're gonna
put it out this summer so this summer
Tacoma FD season four and then yeah
quasi uh on Hulu on Hulu yeah check it
out buddy honestly like we said this is
a huge influence huge fans love you so
much thank you so much for coming in
Kippy what do you got for him guys we're
over the road adding second shows get
your tickets now before they sell out
we'll see you out there thank you gang
we love you and we'll see you next week
peace